only on cbs this morning cindy larper
joins us to announce the star-studded
lineup
cindy lauper good morning to you and
bravo we see your true color cindy
lauper
hi hi hi so i guess listen oh yeah
i'm all right better question is i know
you're doing good i would imagine you
thought pandemic
who cares it's not going to stop me
clearly it didn't but did you have
doubts if you could pull it off again
for the 10th year
you must have oh my god
we were kind of like i don't know but
you know what
what we got help we we've been working
with
somebody who did it before a director
and it's
it's fantastic i mean we had
so many great artists like cher and
dolly parton and billy porter and boy
george and
amanda shires and jason isbo and jackson
brown and
and uh and young artists like king
prince
princess and and phoebe bridges yeah and
i understand a lot of people and
more people just stop by that will stop
by like um like taylor swift and billy
irish and ben miller and ll cool j and i
mean
the fact that they understand the
situation
and that we can do this together and
make it better
um is is a big deal not only that
they believe i think all of us are
craving music at this particular time i
really do i think music has such a
universal healing property so i'm so
glad you're pulling it off and i hear
tick tock is going to be very big have
you done tick tock before
this performance is going to be live on
tickets yes okay
yes it's on my tick tock on the 11th
and then on the 13th which is my good
luck number
it's it's gonna be on my youtube
channel and my facebook and it's
a lot of fun and um you
could watch it dance around have some
fun
listen be moved and donate some
keep us going yeah it's a tradition
every time this year
so it'll be you know i think it you
could do
both you could you could entertain and
i think that rock and roll on a scale
could save the world
i always believed in that and hey right
yep rocky roll right you co-founded you
wrote you co-founded true colors united
back in 2008 as we said you've been
doing this
concert for 10 years do you think this
issue is is getting the attention it
deserves
well honestly this year
this we we are working with the u.n
um i was given a an award and we will
premiere
the little commercial that we did
with the u.n and the fact that the un
acknowledges that this
is an international issue and
that um these youth are only homeless
because of who they are this is a
fixable situation
we can fix this and and we are
working to eradicate this situation for
lgbtq plus
and for youth of color and we are
focused
on making it happen we work on a local
level
we work on a state level why is it so
personal for you cindy
why is it so pre because you could you
could lend your name to many things and
your efforts why is this one so personal
for you
because i'm a friend and family member
and where i come from you don't stand by
and watch your friends and family i'm
stripped of
either civil rights or or yeah
were you ever having a home that's civil
rights were you ever homeless yeah
actually yeah i was for a law
in the united in in new york that you
had to be
21 to sign a lease and i didn't have
anybody to sign a lease so
i wound up in vermont and
i went to a youth hostel that turned out
to be
it turned out to be a place for
homeless runaways for runaways and they
thought i was a runway because they
thought i looked young
but they helped me and i actually went
to college in vermont i
finished i got my ged it was at a time
where they had
programs to help people i was because i
was on welfare for a minute
and i didn't want to be on welfare i
wanted to be
learning and working i actually went up
to the woman i said can you give me a
job
police i just want a job and she sent me
to the sky
and he started talking to me said what
would you like to do i wound up working
with animals
and honestly gail i didn't think i was
ever
going to be famous i thought i would
just work with animals
you know and not people we're glad
you're famous we're glad you work with
animals
because your music is so great anthony
just remind me i forgot about kinky
boots
because i've seen kinky boots twice and
anthony pointed out he knows all things
music
that you wrote all the music to kinky
boots what was the other one you just
said
spongebob and spongebob and you're
working on working girl right
we worked yes i'm working on working
girl yeah we well
i worked on spongebob with my friend
rob hyman who i wrote time after time
with so are you more creative than
quarantine and pandemic are you more
creative or your creative juices
flowing well i you know what
um i had to it forced me to be
innovative
you know when you're sitting there and
you can't get to
anything i learned how to work pro tools
i mean i'm not a genius at it but i can
record my own voice
and it's amazing because once i started
doing that
i i even thought to myself oh my gosh i
forgot
i can sing i mean it's kind of stupid to
think like that
but i hadn't sung yeah and i
i thought and i just remembered the
feeling of singing
you know even when i started i thought
oh i was great
i wasn't great but it felt great to sing
right and
that's what i miss all the time you know
yeah so
i'm i i had to learn and i'm still
learning i mean to do this thing
i had to learn i had to learn how to
deal with
um editors and and
and how to do remote stuff and you know
i'm still
learning sounds like you figured it out
from my friend's studio yeah
all right cindy lawford thank you so
much for being with us this morning
and you can still sing cyndi lauper yes
you can yeah
love your voice